les mesures de sécurité sont renforcées
sur l'eau comme dans les airs l'arrivée
du président américain à l'ONU ne passe
jamais inaperçu mais avec le nouveau
tournant que prend la guerre en Ukraine
avec cette menace nucléaire à peine
voilée de Vladimir Poutine et l'annonce
d'une mobilisation de milliers de
réservistes russes sur le front
ukrainien
les attentes à l'égard de Joe Biden et
de son discours étaient encore plus
grande le soir
décidé par un seul homme visant à
anéantir le droit d'exister de l'Ukraine
déterminé à l'effacer de la carte la
Russie doit en subir les conséquences
sans quoi les principes défendus par
l'ONU seront tous menacés
au Conseil de sécurité devrait être
évité le nombre de membres permanents et
non permanents augmentés un appel à la
réforme qui n'est pas nouveau mais le
contexte de la guerre en Ukraine
confirme sa nécessité selon le président
de la Lettonie
sécurité
n'est pas si simple à mettre en œuvre
entre le problème c'est que ni les
membres permanents ni par ailleurs les
membres des Nations Unies Atlas donc les
membres de l'assemblée générale ne sont
d'accord sur les critères le nombre et
éventuellement les candidats à la
réforme à l'accession au Conseil de
sécurité une réforme qui ne se fera donc
pas du jour au lendemain entre temps les
leaders utilisent les outils
diplomatiques à leur disposition pour
tenter de freiner les visites de la
Russie dans un message enregistré le
président
ukrainien exige qu'elle soit punie
c'est que tout le monde puisse mettre
maintenant le maximum de pression sur le
président Poutine pour qu'il cesse cette
guerre qui n'a plus aucun sens
à la communauté internationale et à
l'opinion publique et même si le
brillait par son absence ce n'est
peut-être pas un hasard si Vladimir
Poutine a choisi de faire sa déclaration
belliqueuse au moment de l'assemblée
générale annuelle ici Madeleine Morin
Radio-Canada New York